what is hate speech and should the
government ban it
we asked college students at the
University of Southern California
if somebody uses a racial slur that's it
speech yeah I think that would be a
reason to like a crime what if somebody
says Muslims shouldn't be allowed to
enter the u.s.
yeah what if somebody denies the
Holocaust hey no I don't have any
understanding for that you shouldn't be
able to blatantly lie about something
especially like the Holocaust a female
comedian says men are scum I don't
believe that's all white people are
racist
the first amendment grants absolute
protection of even the most vile speech
so long as it doesn't directly incite
violence but is the tide turning in
America 40 percent of Americans now
believe the government should regulate
so-called hate speech but it turns out
that defining hate speech is easier said
than done nobody on things this is hate
speech this is hate speech many who
advocate hate speech laws in 2018 seem
motivated by what they see is the rise
of Trump ISM feel that raw and hateful
rhetoric on the right and college
campuses have become the epicenter of
the free speech debate with incidents of
college students shouting down and even
physically attacking controversial
speakers becoming an increasingly common
occurrence so we talked to students at
the university of southern california
about free speech and hate speech one
common refrain on campus is that hateful
speech is actually equivalent to
violence do you think hate speech by
itself is an act of violence I do
now your words can't I physically harm
someone
I think violence is more than physical
it's emotional psychological if hate
speech is violence maybe it makes sense
to regulate it like Canada Australia and
most of Europe do many of the students
we spoke to seemed open to the idea I
think if people can understand the power
of words and maybe hate the beach's
violence could help us have restrictions
that are not damaging or that could stop
at a certain place those kind of
opinions are better said left unsaid
because it just incites violence and
hatred among everyone you know are you
in favor of regulations that would stop
people from doing that or though it can
make that a crime yes I would have no
problem if it is regulated but then who
determines what constitutes hate speech
while most respondents to a recent poll
agree that hate speech is immoral
eighty-two percent said it would be
difficult to ban because people can't
agree in what is hateful could people
form a consensus around whether these
things are hate speech generally not
think it would be really hard to agree
and and so does that give you pause and
you know make you think like maybe maybe
the regulation would not want do what I
would hope it would do yeah obviously
that would be ideal if something like
that could be into place I just don't
really see how it works
so for I'll give you an example so there
was a French comedian and he was jailed
more than anti-semitic joke would you
support that type of action no
advocates of hate speech laws often say
that racists cloaked themselves in the
veil of free speech to attack vulnerable
populations but social media provides
examples of how speech codes often
backfire and hurt the very minorities
they are intended to protect Facebook
and Twitter are private companies free
to ban whatever they deemed to be hate
speech but their attempts to do so have
resulted in bans of feminists saying
that all white men are trash and the
platform suspended rapper Lil B for
posting that white people are the only
ones who really love the guns you can
tell they are violent people hateful
speech might be hurtful stupid or just
plain wrong but if we deprive ourselves
of the opportunity to hear it we also
lose the opportunity to rebut it and the
person who's willing to speak forbidden
words gains a special power when Austria
imprisoned historian David Irving for
Holocaust denial he was greeted with a
hero's welcome by crowd of 10,000 in
Budapest shortly after his release the
government had turned him into a martyr
in America attempts to shut down or
shout down speakers have almost
certainly backfired as well by boosting
the visibility of provocateurs like
Miley innopolis they're bringing drugs
they're bringing crime they're rapists
and some I assume are good people
Trump saying any of these things should
definitely be regulated because he has
so much influence and he was saying
these in speeches and stuff patrol
saying things about minorities like
Hispanics and women and Muslims
does it concern you that if the
government is the one that's regulating
these things that people like Trump
would be the one deciding what is
protected speech and what it's done yeah
of course that's another
granting the government the power to
decide what's acceptable to say presumes
that what brings us closer to the truth
is not the free exchange of ideas but
the wise decision-making of politicians
and many of the college students we
spoke to agreed that being exposed to
challenging and even threatening ideas
is an important aspect of the
intellectual journey and what do you
think about people shutting down
speakers on campuses I don't like that
at all honestly like I follow a lot of
what goes on at Berkeley or they like
protesting not how far right speakers
comment I think that's dangerous to be
perfectly honest here at USC and on
college campuses it's important that we
hear everything we possibly can whether
that be something that we don't like or
something that rubs us the wrong way I
think it's important that we hear it
because we're gonna go out into the
world and we're going to hear it there
and it's important that we're able to
hear it here and form our own opinions
or own ideas
[Music]